whenever you go on to a new website that
you have not been on before you may be
greeted with the dialog box that asks
you if you want to enable cookies but
what even our cookies are you tracking
you
[Music]
welcome to hearts all B's a computer
cookie or as it is more formally known
an HTTP cookie is basically just a file
historian web browser that mainly stores
our preferences for example this could
include things like your preferred
language the preferred view style and
your preferred zoom level cookies are
also often used to keep track of your
visits and activities to certain
websites while this may sound intrusive
this actually sometimes very necessary
and quite useful for instance whenever
you are shopping on Amazon or any online
retailer for that matter whenever you
ask some accurate card a cookie is what
tracks what is inside your car without
cookies every time you clicked a new
link on that website your cart would
become empty and finally one of the most
popular uses of cookies is autofill when
you're logging on to your email for the
20th time that day or in your eyes
define your billing address yet again
it's cookies that help autofill this if
you have it on of course now there are
three main types of cookies but they are
all really easy to understand and quite
simple the first type is obsession
cookie
these cookies are only used your and
actively browsing through a website when
you leave the website these cookies are
also deleted the second type is tracking
cookies and these are your long-term
type cookies and these are what
advertisers and many websites use to
personalize things to you for example
the suggested videos and products on
YouTube and Amazon and the personalized
as you see are all based on these types
of cookies tracking cookies are such a
long term records of your multiple
visits to the same site finally got your
authentication cookies these are pretty
self-explanatory these track and fed
users logged in and if so under what aim
and these are also by autofill your
logins now our cookies dangerous and
should you be
ahsha's of them well generally cookies
cannot transfer viruses and malware onto
your computer because the data on
cookies does not change where it travels
back and forth so essentially a cookie
just can't suddenly become malicious for
no apparent reason however something
that can be harmful is viruses and
malware darkus guys dis cookies super
cookies and zombie cookies are
definitely something to look out for
fortunately super cookies can be turned
off on most major browsers nowadays as
for zombie cookies what these are is
every time that a zombie cookies deleted
it actually regenerates and is actually
a very big hassle to deal with but as
long as you have the right settings
turned on you should be able to easily
stay away from these types of cookies
nowadays main concern is about
third-party tracking cookies dude how to
monitor and collect data about your
online activity and unfortunately this
can become a security and privacy issue
if this information falls into wrong
hands however a simple solution is to
just turn off cookies all together
however before you pull the trigger it
is important to remember that cookies
were invented to enhance your browsing
experience and even the companies that
gooey factor information are usually
big-name companies like Google and
Facebook and you can rest assured that
your information will not be used for
anything namely bad it will most likely
just be used to personalize the apps to
you and hope they drive more sales for
them and you can turn out personalized
ads itself with Doc turning off cookies
as a whole overall cookies are in place
to improve your online experience but
with all the tracking and
personalization that's going on nowadays
privacy and security can become a
primary concerns however turning those
cookies all together can make navigating
some websites unnecessarily difficult
and make logging in a big hassle the
best solution would probably be to limit
and control third-party tracking cookies
so you can protect your privacy but not
turn off he says a hole so that you
don't lose out on the benefit
this way you can enjoy your online
browsing experience while being safe so
don't miss anything about cookies also
what computer or hardware concept would
you like me to cover next make sure
comment down below what you guys think
also if you guys like this video then
make sure to drop a like and consider
subscribing if you would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
then I'm Hardy I'll see you guys next
[Music]